[Music]
we got emergency off the record we got
to do okay let's do it emergency
still careful
we i mean we're gonna we're gonna start
trying to incorporate the two okay
careful boy uh what's on the record
because it's it's actually news
they're kind of the body of brian landry
just now what confirm
dental records oh [ __ ] wait so did he
kill himself he killed the chicken then
he killed himself no cause of death
nobody knows that fbi is going to let us
know today really he went into the
forest or hiding or whatever he could
have just died out there
just hiding oh yeah like not killed
himself like he could have just [ __ ]
starved and [ __ ] he's not an eagle scout
like anthony yeah if he was an eagle
scout he would have [ __ ] been chill
dude he would have been fine nope he
couldn't [ __ ] tie those knots you're
in like uh florida right now florida
yeah he could eat like an alligator or
something on a florida trail it's always
so not satisfying when the murderer also
dies i know
unless he got murdered unless he got
murdered because
by like the family or something
the murderer yeah by the real killer
that's always interesting my third
killer this is like a tv show all of a
sudden they're saying that they found
some like um
other
body
like
remains with
the uh the stuff that he had or whatever
yeah they're saying they found partial
human remains it's not it's they just
confirmed that it belongs to him with
dental records okay
and um
they told
brian's parents
and then they basically um
you know
help where they were able to help
confirm i wonder how long he was dead
for
for them to see the body being
completely unidentifiable you know yeah
and decomposed wait did they just find
like a skeleton is that what i so i i'm
not super keeping up to date with what's
happening i said decompose i don't know
what that means you're saying remains
and then they said dental records so
we're just assuming so just bones and
maybe some like random ass flesh that
didn't get they literally said dental
records michael okay who knows
stop guessing keeps guessing oh is it a
hat no it's it the teeth it's bright
with his initials on it was it rotted
was it
like that
the only way i can uh believe these
dental records dude mike would say some
[ __ ] exactly is it with his history well
he could have been wearing a tooth
necklace
[Laughter]
oh my god with his own teeth on it
because that's what serial killer
michael's just like how did he do it i
need to know how he did it
how'd he get away yo i'm all about these
details i just gotta know who's your
favorite serial killer of all time mike
you know i actually don't know very very
serial killers like the funniest
question top five favorite ones are the
ones haven't been caught yet
you wouldn't know about it you're not
he's like me
he's on that list dude dude also there
was a guy who kind of looks like brian
landry i guess and he was just hiking oh
yeah i heard about this
and then a bunch of guys in riot shields
with u.s marshals written on that no
really like confronted him and pointing
guns at his face wait were they some
like volunteers with your marshall seal
no dude they they i think someone saw
this cat walking around he did look like
him really he had a bald head he had a
beard and i guess that's all you really
need have you guys been following this
because um when it first broke out i was
like what's going on you know this is
[ __ ] crazy a youtuber i didn't know
that they had a youtube channel all this
stuff and then
the most interesting part was the
uploaded footage by the police
department body camera the body cam and
you can see the whole thing and it
obviously looks like a bad relationship
you know apparently there's a secret
body cam video oh secret party kittens
they keep it secret what's so secret
about it is with brian laundry's death
confirmed well secret gabby potato body
cam video she had one too news we can
confirm part of a film encounter between
brian landry his girlfriend gabby capita
utah's mob police moab police continue
to be held back from the public for the
foreseeable future
because they need to use it for core
body cam footage showing the aftermath
of an alleged fight between brian
laundry and his girlfriend gabby patino
don't tell charles not to call trans fix
the nature when i was released
footage from two cameras attached to
police officers showed the explosive
immediate aftermath of a reported
altercation between the two in the car
however authorities have confirmed their
intention to continue withholding clips
from a third police camera damn dude
also there's an fbi agent who thought
that he was being taken care of recently
he came a couple weeks ago and said that
he thinks the reason why we haven't
found him yet is because somebody's
helping him yeah a lot of people suspect
the parents cooperating with or like not
cooperating with the police is that
misdirected actually
because when that [ __ ] came home
um
when gabby's parents were like oh where
is she whatever they wouldn't even tell
them that she didn't come home with her
with him
interesting so they're saying they they
were accomplice i see that's the
suspicion yeah because he came back he
bought a phone from atnt and then left
it at his parents house or in the car
that he left in the woods or whatever
the [ __ ] and he disappeared so they all
think and then they talk about the
communication yeah the parents pick uh
use that phone so it's like there's like
a hole yeah there's a whole burner
so so somebody was dropping off [ __ ]
apples
to this [ __ ] yeah so he stayed he was
definitely getting hooked up i think
because he's got a high frame
[Applause]
but maybe he killed himself after a
certain amount of time but some i mean
dude the fact that he didn't get caught
from for a month or month there was a
manhunt like a like a nationwide major
dog the bounty hunter was on him maybe
dog about it or killed him
he had to have been dead though like
relatively soon after gabby petito yeah
sounds kind of easy to get get with
murder huh
get away with it as long as you don't
survive i think it's super easy to get
away with murder if you don't care about
if you live or go to jail hey that's a
fake body then what do you think about
all the people who do get away with
murder it's pretty crazy look i mean
during the search they found like nine
other people's remains
the search for nah it's not gabby potato
[ __ ]
legal let's go how many of those are
accidents and murders right
or even like driving back and forth from
vegas there's just like empty land right
i'm like what if i just carried a body
deep into the desert and then [ __ ]
dug up i guarantee you
when the mob ran las vegas they murdered
so many [ __ ] just watch the
movie casino joe pesci that [ __ ]
killed so many people joe pesci dude how
come he hasn't been caught yet
i don't know what his name was on was it
nikki
uh but the the fbi agent was saying that
all fugitives tire eventually many of
them end up being on the run for well
over a decade so then obviously holy
[ __ ] yeah so obviously this is a much
different
dude
because he was founded just now
damn
unless marshall seems like a cool job
because all you're doing is getting
fugitives
and transporting high uh high-profile
criminals from courts to courts all i
think so you're like a uber for
criminals that's tight uh a cat a hunter
bounty hunter uber yeah that's all you
like boba fett
is that elbow fat dutch yeah wow
like django
yeah
like django unchained
okay yeah but you're just catching bad
guys bad fellas but isn't chewie a part
of that crew too
chewy is a bounty hunter yeah yeah yeah
he's a dude he's like with them right
but he's kind of furry isn't he
nice-looking he's very furry doug the
bounty hunter is the most prolific
[ __ ] bounty hunter of all time though
dog i can't believe dog didn't find this
guy i know
he's got rusty huh he probably did and
they discredited him bro oh that's what
it is it's also out of his turf though
he might not know that it's not hawaii
yeah you got a florida
that's as close to the you as it gets
but he doesn't have the same connects
the contacts like the guy who pays off
at the corner the homeless guy in a
shopping cart that he could ask
questions about that's true hawaii is
pretty small all those
clue givers pigeons
my buddy worked on a pool
in that neighborhood where about a dog
dog the bounty hunter lives and he says
devil has a big portrait of himself on
the house
lit
so you drive by the neighborhood you
could see which one's his house because
it's a big mural of himself
that's classic
i know
but yeah they're saying that um yeah
like you said the parents have come
under scrutiny but they denied helping
their son so that's interesting too
because like like i remember this is
like 15 years ago or something i had a
bunch of [ __ ] card payment um tickets
from not paying the city when i got um
those parking tickets oh because you
probably lived in like hollywood or
something i lived in i lived in
koreatown it was crazy with those six
signs on tuesday but not thursday but
before five after seven so they on
purpose they came to impound my truck
eventually because the tickets they
double after a certain amount of time oh
[ __ ] and i wasn't living in and
i was living in greece i'm not in san
diego where they want to get me and then
my truck and my dad was like
i don't know where he's i'm no [ __ ]
clueless damn your dad's a gangster
but like imagine [ __ ] in the bathroom
no but imagine like you know now your
your kids want it for murder or
something crazy like what kicks into
gear is it like your parent your parents
will want to protect your kid and keep
keep them okay oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] the law
right but also
my kid's a murderer
[ __ ] do i have to murder them now wow
today's video is brought to you by tushy
all right i have to give a huge shout
out to tushy because they sent me a
nice little bidet five years ago and i
still have it today even though i move i
bring it with me everywhere if i could
bring it to every single toilet i would
because it is a life and game changer
using a bidet it's completely air
replaceable if you've ever had diarrhea
which i know everyone has don't don't
don't fake don't front out there because
i know you have to
sometimes when you wipe you know like
even as much as you want to wipe as
clean as possible you don't get
everything with the tushy it blasts it
nice and clean to the point where my
wife can lick it if she wants to and
i'll kiss her after it you know that's
how much i trust how much it's like
taking a bath and a shower at the same
time in a very specific area yeah
because sometimes you're you're dressed
in a suit because you're about to do
some secret asian stuff yeah like you're
about to be a spot and do spy things we
don't have time to take a full shower
nope but you know you're gonna get your
ass lick later so you want it to be
clean yeah but also the cool thing of it
all is it's really easy to install like
you don't really need a plug for
electronics or anything like that it
just hooks up straight to the uh the
flushing mechanism of your toilet i
don't know what it's called but it uses
the water of that pressure and it's
really like diddly do who are you it's
so easy you know we do all right yeah
and that's why i think it's like super
simple it attaches to your toilet seat
all that really easy to use and
you know me i got a fresh booty hole
because of that
so if you're looking for a clean booty
hole go to hellotushy.com off the record
to get 10
off plus free shipping this is a special
deal for our listeners only go to
hellotushi.com off the record to get 10
off after you buy and install your two
sheets don't forget to add us and tag
hellotushy so we can see what your
bathrooms look like thank you guys
i think that's what you have to do i
think it depends on the law the crime
the age because i remember in fifth
grade
um like everyone was into stealing and
then i went to save ons and i stole like
a bunch of like mechanical pencils i
thought they were sick
and then this is on a tuesday where so
my parents were divorced and so my dad
would see me on tuesdays and wednesdays
and he picked me up from school and we
went to mcdonald's that was our go-to
thing every tuesday and i was like dad i
go take a piss and i don't know how he
knows this catches me all the time [ __ ]
this fool but we're going to we're going
to mcdonald's and i'm because my pockets
were bulging right so i don't be walking
around with plastic that's how he's
catching your ass so i'm starting to
take them all out of the packaging and
then i could like put in my pockets and
my dad comes in and i was in the in the
[ __ ] so he kicks the door open what
the [ __ ] are you doing in there
devil breaks down a mcdonald's bathroom
oh i'm just organizing my pencils and he
goes you [ __ ] stole them of course
beats my ass in there and then he takes
me back to save on and he goes tell them
that you stole from them
and then and that's why saveon doesn't
exist no more because you kept stealing
they don't get enough you put them out
of business bro i was like [ __ ] this is
crazy i thought my dad would like i
thought he was gonna kick my ass and end
it there yeah but he he made you return
it yeah he took me to save on and then
he told uh the person at the front desk
to call the cops on me
oh my god and then did they do it no
he's like no it's okay you know i'm a
kid so he's like no it's okay he brought
it back that's fine he doesn't want to
call the police needs to learn call the
police needs to learn dude my mom did
that to me too dude your parents are
north korea and you guys yeah for real i
was stealing candy out of the remember
the candy bags yeah i don't know i would
steal some and i thought i was so slick
i was like my mom was like waiting for
me in the aisle and i was like hold on i
want to just check something i feel like
seven or eight and i'm like slowly
looking at [ __ ] boxes up there while
i'm grabbing candy and putting in my
pocket and i walk down the aisle she's
like what's your pocket oh my [ __ ] what
are you talking about what are you
talking about she pulls out my pockets
there's a bunch of [ __ ] candy that i
stole did you hit your right then in
there dude she smacked the shot of me
and then and then she went to the
security guard and she says i'm gonna
call the cops right now let's go and i'm
like cry like no please
all right i had to put the [ __ ] candy
back she's like all right you're gonna
go to jail and i was like freaking the
[ __ ] out the best thing is when a little
kid thinks they're going to jail
i'm going away man [ __ ] dude it's over
i'm five years old my life is over
that's it i had my whole life out of me
and i ruined it dude i [ __ ] ruined it
little seven-year-old nick with a big
ass [ __ ] years and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he's like [ __ ] mom you ratting ass [ __ ]
get directv in prison dude those ears
were giving it away bro i couldn't get
away with anything with those ears
everybody would point at me like yo
those [ __ ] ears are bigger you see
yourself like locked up like this and
going in a [ __ ] jail and [ __ ] i was
crying bro i was a little [ __ ] dude if
i was really hard i would have just like
not cried at all i was kind of a little
[ __ ] too do you guys remember when the
little mermaid movie came out and they
had this little toy that you could dip
in water and it was like a little
flounder or whatever yes
it would squirt water out of his mouth
no
okay
i thought that's where you're going with
this [ __ ] way mike he stayed on brand
he stayed yellow okay okay
but no you squirt water out right so i
was at my friend's house i didn't get
that toy my friend had that toy i don't
even know i was like five years old or
some [ __ ] and i just like took the toy i
was like this is a sick toy thank you
very much all right but i knew enough
not to like announce that i was taking
the toilet i knew that i was you had to
be slick i knew i was stealing the toy
yeah and then uh i get home and i'm like
immediately get home i'm so excited i
[ __ ] put in the sink and i'm like
splashing the little thing i'm like this
is so sick and my mom is like what where
what's that where'd you get that
like she immediately knew that that was
not mine and i was like oh i you know
nowhere no nothing and all that [ __ ] you
know and then she made me take it back
to the she drove me right back to their
house
knocked on the door and made me give
back while i was crying and [ __ ] your
mom ratted you out you have this thing
where it's not it's kind of a joke cause
it's funny but it's kind of serious so
like every time tyka goes to his
cousin's house he always come like in
the car ride back he has like a new
spider or [ __ ] new like hot wheeled
or something i'm like where'd you get
that from he goes oh dominic conduct
that's his his cousin's and i'm like did
you ask if you can have it he goes no
i'm like that's stealing and so every
time we would come every time we visit
again we would be returning the toys i
stole that now before he leaves we
literally do a pat down like at the door
like he's tsa yeah he's like david we're
[ __ ] patting that he does this
yeah we're like this [ __ ]
do you let him play with it in the
meantime until you until you bring it
back i do i know you do
what lesson is he getting you [ __ ]
enabler i love it unbelievable it's now
just the system you and you [ __ ]
you're really great up for toys yeah
he's like i played with him for a month
like blockbuster why is he not getting
his ass beat yeah
he's checking into the new toys boy
father the [ __ ] ear in the room
[Laughter]
but in this situation just to go back to
your question though like what as a
parent would you do um
hypothetically maybe these parents
didn't know that brian murdered her like
what would you do then you don't like i
mean like
somebody's like hey your kid's a
murderer but you're like i don't
actually know if they i don't know you
think it's wishful thinking though well
that's true because he could be lying to
his parents because like if i was a [ __ ]
bag right like let's say
um
i murdered her and then i'm like oh [ __ ]
what i do what i do i'm not gonna tell
my parents uh just be like oh uh yeah
mom and dad i lost her in the forest and
now everyone's gonna think that i killed
her i don't know what to do yeah yeah
you know exactly what he said
but a decent parent would be like let's
go to the police that's what my mom
would have nothing to hide that's what
everyone yeah your parents would
probably not only say let's go to the
police don't say what did you [ __ ] do
to her right yeah his fans are like
run
right
just get a [ __ ] burner phone and then
i'm gonna [ __ ] go and give you some
messages they got ideas already they got
a whole list of [ __ ] that happens if
their son's a [ __ ] murderer yeah if
kobach's ready to go they knew their son
was a murderer i would [ __ ]
i would i don't know i think i'd have to
believe my kid even if they were lying
like just like the the
the natural i just yeah i just have to
the first question is anthony's bigger
than my kid
because
i'm hoping that
my kid grows up to be big and strong but
still a little [ __ ]
because i could [ __ ] his ass up if he if
he comes home and says stuff like this
and then i got because i have to think
like i can't i'm in line with his son
what about you what would you do i don't
know i feel like if i was the parents
and i heard that like i would almost not
want to know mike would never go to his
parents he's not messy like you don't
have a friend you have to just not want
to know why
that's not the scenario don't give a
trail dude nobody would know the people
there if her kid came to you it was like
hey dad
i think i killed someone i didn't hear
that
maybe like
because they look at this situation
news everywhere family news reporters
outside your house they're like talk to
you and you're just like nah i don't
want to know about this
i feel like i would be like well there's
a lot of stuff that we don't know about
this case so you know let's just do more
investigation you'd be the greatest
interview on television
you would already be a suspect for
saying that dude you just immediately
but i wouldn't be because i haven't done
anything i think
how does he do this this is like for
people who who don't understand like
we've played mafia with this guy for so
long that's how he gets himself killed
he's such a wild card nobody knows
i'll be mafia and mike will talk like
that and i'm like [ __ ] is this guy mafia
too like i don't have a [ __ ] knife no
i'm not
saying i'm like oh he's making a good
point and then the end he just blows it
dude i think i feel so guilty for the
other family
like
like even if it was an accident so like
let's say like gabby's family to go yeah
like like what if what if it's not like
a murder right but like they went on a
road trip together and then like
she died because they were kayaking or
whatever drowned whatever like right and
then it wasn't even malicious i'd still
feel [ __ ] horrible that yeah
that my [ __ ] [ __ ] went out there and
killed somebody or got somebody in
trouble or act like an accident happened
because of their wild ideas
yeah yeah i like when you explain them
as you're coming my [ __ ] kind my
piece of [ __ ] a piece of me went out
there it only took 18 minutes to start
talking about company yeah
good today hey
well because we had to give it some
respect man this is [ __ ] crazy it's
crazy no it's hard i still think you're
being pretty respectful about it
alternating though i think the the real
victim here is like the uh gabby's like
and get in the family and everyone
because there's still no closure nobody
really knows my mind is the laundry
family didn't help no and that that's
what the
this this one of the law enforcement guy
says he says the landry's did not help
us find gabby and they're sure not going
to help us find brian like that's pretty
like i heard they're getting in trouble
i heard the city of uh of the city the
state of florida is going to try to
persecute them or no that's their
attorney okay so the attorney for
petito's family said that but still it's
like gabby patil i think the cause of
death was like strangulation right like
she she was found oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so
that's pretty crazy
yeah that's whole that's so hard right
because it's like a part of me would be
like man my son's a [ __ ] douchebag
man you're a piece of [ __ ] but it's also
my son right so it's like damn i want to
[ __ ] abuse your ass for abusing this
girl but it's like maybe that's what
caused your abuse to this girl because i
abused you
so i i accidentally used her it's a
christopher nolan movie you know
and if he's a piece of [ __ ] like let's
say you're like all right fine the only
fair thing to do is chop off one of your
hands yeah he but because he's a piece
of [ __ ] he might hate you and kill you
in your
your sleep patricide that's what i'm
saying what did brian died because his
[ __ ] parents just said you know what
you're a piece of [ __ ] i created a
monster
well he's still a monster he's still got
to be
yeah
ah i don't know what a dumb date but
joe's saying like he rather injury bring
the kid in and then deal with the family
style
you know so within the family style does
he kill them
do we do an eye for an eye or something
or sure my son and there was proof
strangled a chick you guys strangled him
back i don't know if i can dude
i don't know you you would let like the
other family strangle him in this like
situation you know what
collusion yeah you collude with the
other family i'll i would
that gangster thing and peaky blinders
did it yeah i think so like the other
family is a [ __ ] and you're like all
right go strangle my son like now we're
not going to do that like what are you
talking about the black hand the
vendetta i only saw one episode so i
don't know what you're talking about
so if the other family was like let's
say they were like quakers or some [ __ ]
and then they're like we're pacifists we
don't believe in that i'm like i'll do
it myself yeah you put yourself in a
guillotine i always liked the old school
like like head in the burlap sack i
always thought that was dope yeah and
then in the water jar here you go sir
oh that
little special delivery for you yeah
you're welcome
hey here's your postmates
you know we don't have a fun joke we
don't have like a version of like an
honorable death
right in like our society yeah like in
an old japanese culture there might have
been right oh yeah you kill yourself and
your homie sliced your head off exactly
but that's dope i like kind of like
[ __ ] do honorable deaths here for
anybody who wants to hold on to some
sort of integrity or to clear their
family's name like that
that stuff only applied to warrior
culture so like for the rest
80 percent of the population they didn't
do anything like cowards yeah
so the flu players couldn't cut kill
themselves so they [ __ ] up on a no
there was no point to be ashamed of a
flu plane
you know
it's only warriors [ __ ] up yeah
it's just like no one there to cut your
head off that's why they were basically
owned by the warlords like pretty much
everyone was enslaved band practice was
crazy though
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you